asian people look at me like i'm not
asian
because i don't have it i'm not you know
what i'm saying i was brought up
different you for me so when they hear
me talk
they hear me move they see how i'm
maneuvering [ __ ]
they don't look at me like i'm asian but
at the end of the day
i never let how they look at me dictate
my stance for my people you feel me i
know that's some weak that's some weak
[ __ ]
you know what i mean like yo if people
look at them [ __ ] them i don't give a
[ __ ] about asian people like
i'm saying i hang out with with black
people anyway i would never do that
you know what i'm saying if i see
somebody even if he don't accept me as
an
asian i'm always going to stand up for
the [ __ ] because at the end of
the day
i'm a representation for my people my
people is because
nobody's going to respect me if i just
let my people get
yeah i'm saying yeah i mean i remember
you you i think was a little pump you
called out
yeah but i mean but like i but you've
but you've always been a very
vocal representative as i should of
course
as if you weren't you people look at you
crazy